I think that, and I talk about this in
some depth in the book,
there are two misperceptions people,
even very brilliant people, labor under
that I think are really going to keep us from
imagining memory the way we knew we need to.
The first is this period of information inflation
that we're living through.
People think that it's created by computers and that
it's the first time in history that this has ever happened.
This is a moment that's never happened before
Wrong on two counts. Every information technology
when it's new creates a kind of vertigo.
In this case it's a digital vertigo but, as I'll show you,
there's always a vertigo. And the other
misconception we have is about memory itself.
Because memory is not data storage.
Memory in fact is a biological feature of all creatures.
And the first step in making robust memories over time
is to forget. And the reason that we have memory
to begin with, that nature has endowed all creatures
with it, is because memory is not about the past.
It is about the future. If we were born only with DNA
we'd all perish second or third day in life.
And that's true even of amoebas. So with that,
I want to start with talking a little bit about technology.
Many of you will recognize this is one of the first
and certainly the most durable information technology
that humans have created.
It's a clay tablet also known as a cuneiform.
Technology is a tool that's created by human beings.
Technologies have no powers of their own.
They only have the powers that we
endow those technologies with.
And the technologies especially around memory
are usually invented to solve a problem
or to meet some kind of a market demand.
Now about 5000 years ago when the scribes
in Mesopotamia invented these clay tablets
what they were responding to was the need
to keep track of goods and services
in exchange or in storage.
So they were basically accountants that invented writing
but within a relatively short period of time
a couple thousand years
--in Sumerian time that's relatively quick--
the technology began to acquire
lots of different capacities and develop
certain potentials in human beings that were
totally unanticipated by the accountants.
Another lesson for technologists today,
if they think they understand anything about the uses
the future uses of what they create.
In fact what they came up with fairly quickly,
and this tablet is about 2700 years old,
is uses including prayers and omens.
If you could actually read this...
I just want to point out incidentally that
like the Rosetta Stone this is actually eye legible
it's a wonderful technology we can still read it today.
And if you did read Akkadian...
Does anybody in the audience read Akkadian?
Good. I'll get no quizzes on what it says.
But I do know that it's filled with divinations
about omens from animals
and human birth defects telling us about
what the future is going to be.
So if you were able to read this you would know
that in fact cuneiforms were very quickly recruited to
do something that accountants never dreamt about.
The first recorded poem that we have,
the epic Gilgamesh, uses this technology.
And as you may know Gilgamesh is actually an epic
about a man who wanted to become immortal.
So, very appropriate.